Salut à toi, membre de la team Mentalo !
Oui, je fais encore cette vidéo en dehors de la maison,
parce que je suis encore en date de spectacle
Je vais refaire honneur à une vielle habitude, qu'on avait ensemble toute l'année,
d'habitude le Dimanche je vous donnais une explication pour essayer de bluffer les gens.
Pour les bluffer ce Dimanche ou n'importe quel jour de la semaine peu importe.
Après ça te regarde.
Alors c'est parti, on va refaire ça aujourd'hui,
Je vous le dis tout de suite on est sur du "safe", on est sur un truc à 100%.
Il n'y a pas de possibilité de rater ça. C'est complètement logique,
j'ai testé ça depuis quelques semaines avec les potes à droite à gauche.
Et leur réaction est assez surprenante.
Vous demandez à trois personnes de choisir un chiffre dans leur tête.
Un chiffre secret, ils le disent à personne, il y a que eux qui l'ont en tête.
Et vous demandez au troisième de sortir son téléphone et de le mettre sur la fonction calculatrice.
Il passe alors sont téléphone à la première personne, et la première personne
tape le chiffre qu'elle a en tête ensuite elle appuie sur multiplier par 2,
ensuite elle fait + 3. Et elle le passe à la personne suivante.
La personne suivante fait multiplier par 5, ajoute (donc fait plus)
sont chiffre secret à elle. Et le passe à la troisième personne.
Et enfin la troisième personne elle fait "fois 10",
Et ensuite elle ajoute, donc elle fait "+", son chiffre secret à elle,
et elle appuie sur égal et elle a récupéré son téléphone en même temps,
c'est plutôt pratique. A partir de ce moment soit vous regardez vous même
sur le téléphone le résultat final, ça crée pas d'indice, c'est complètement aléatoire.
Soit vous le demandez directement à la troisième personne.
Et instantanément vous serez en mesure de savoir qui a tapé quoi.
Pour ça c'est très simple il suffit de soustraire mentalement
150 au résultat final, alors si vous avez du mal à soustraire 150,
vous faites -100 puis ensuite vous faites -50.
Et grâce au nouveau résultat dans votre tête, vous allez connaître
le chiffre de chacun.
Puisque le premier chiffre, celui des centaine ça va être celui  qu'a tapé
le premier spectateur. Le deuxième, celui des dizaines, celui du deuxième spectacteur.
Et celui des unités celui du troisième spectateur.
Un exemple concret : si le résulat final c'est 453,
vous faîte "-150" ça fait 303 donc le premier a tapé "3",
le deuxième "0", le dernier "3".
Ça fonctionne très bien, et ce qui est cool c'est que ça
permet de bluffer trois personne en même temps.
Evidemment le présentez pas comme ça, le présentez pas
aussi brut que cette explication, trouvez une manière
de l'enrober, une manière fun de présenter ça, ça sera encore plus bluffant.
Un autre conseil : je vous recommande de faire taper à chaque fois "=",
à chaque étape. Quand il fait "x2" faut qu'il fasse "=" derrière.
Ensuite "+3" faut qu'il fasse "=" derrière, parce que sur certains téléphones comme sur l'iPhone,
ça peut créer une erreur dans le calcul, à cause de la priorité des calculs.
Il va d'abord faire les multiplications puis ensuite les additions.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu et que vous allez la tester surtout !
Revenez ensuite la dessous dans le commentaires et vous me racontez comment ça s'est
passé, vos idées de présentations. Je serais très curieux de lire ça.
Si vous êtes encore là à ce stade de la vidéo vous me le faite savoir
en laissant un pouce en l'air, parce que ça c'est important.
Vous pouvez également vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir,
parce que le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant 1 an,
depuis le  1er Janvier jusqu'au 31 Décembre.
Donc rendez vous demain à 17h. Ciao !!